vanerastro
[Music]
jalastro
[Music]
in these last few years we have been
building the foundation of a universe of
cinema
based on the concept of astras
the astra verse
brahmastra part 1 is the first movie of
this astra verse and it begins with an
image from a mystical time in ancient
india
where a group of sages are performing
deep meditation in the himalayas
and for their meditation the sages are
blessed with the light of the universe
the most powerful
and most pure energy there is
a
shakti
from this brahma shakti astras are born
astras which have within them all the
different energies that are found in
nature fire wind water earth the
jalastra
pavanastra
and the agni astra astras which have
within them the powers of different
animals like the vanarastra which can
give to the person who controls it the
power of a super monkey
and the nandi astra which has within it
the power and strength of a thousand
bulls
but there is one astra
the last one to emerge from the light
carrying its collective essence
the lord of all the others
which the sages name after one of the
most powerful weapons of our gods
the brahmastra
the sages vow to protect these astras
and as the guardians of the brahmastra
they name themselves the brahmans
a secret society which will exist
amongst other men and do good for the
world with the power of these astras
time moves forward humanity progresses
and the brahmans carries on as well
passing on the astras generation to
generation
all the way into our world today where
the brahmans still exist in secret
india as it is today
is where the story of brahmastra is set
i believe this puts us in a very unique
position because no one has done what we
are doing with ancient indian
inspiration in the modern world
ever
and now on to the hero of brahmastra our
protagonist
a young man who is yet to discover
that in this world of astras
he is a miracle
because he is an astra himself
in keeping with our spirit of tribute to
our roots he is named after the god who
is the most dear to me personally the
most mystical the all-powerful and my
greatest inspiration
shiva
trump